hey how you doing today folks in today's
video I'm going to continue my review of
the plot leaked and in this video I'm
going to actually go over episode three
so what I'll do is I'll read the entire
leaked episode and then I'll breakdown
each section of it and discuss what
sounds like it's going to happen what
has been proved in some photos and then
I'll talk about what seems like it could
be made up or is not actually going to
happen next season okay so here we go
episode 3 says John and Davos arrived on
Dragonstone and meet tyrion on the beach
tyrion brings them to meet Daenerys Dany
demands John bend the knee which he
refuses John instead tells her about the
white Walker threat but she doesn't
believe him Davos tries to tell her
about John's resurrection but John
dismisses it
Tyrion steps in to say John's a good guy
and definitely not insane
they any respect John immediately
although John doesn't return to
sentiment Jon meets Theon on the beach
and promises to spare his life for what
he did helping Sansa escape Arya
encounters her old direwolf Nymeria on
the way back to Winterfell Jorah and Sam
meet in Old Town and find a cure for
greyscale bran arrives at Winterfell
when mirror returns home to the neck
okay so that's episode three so let's
break down each section of it and
discuss it says John and Davos arrival
on Dragonstone and meet Tyrion on a
beach now there's no way for me to
dispute this photos I've already came
out that show this exactly happening
exactly as it states in the leak there's
been several photos that show John and
Davos meeting Tyrion on the beach
surrounded by the Dothraki and in a
photo you actually see John and Tyrion
shaking hands so that's definitely going
to happen next season so Styrian brings
them to meet Daenerys which we
definitely know happens as well we've
already seen in the leaked photos John
and Daenerys and several different
photos meeting each other walking
talking stuff like that Dany demands
john to bend the knee which he refuses
to do now there's been no evidence of
this I'm not really sure why she would
do this you think Tyrion what I've
already told you know her about John
if she in fact sends de Ravin out you
think her interion would be talking
about John as he's getting ready to
arrive and he you think tearing would
like well and you know he's a good guy
so you think maybe she wouldn't do that
but you know Danny's she's on a mission
to claim this throne as her own so I can
definitely see her wanting everybody to
respect her and it says John instead
tells her about the white Walker threat
but she doesn't believe him now at first
when I first read this leak for a month
ago or however long ago it came out I
found it's kind of hard to believe at
first and not just out of everybody just
you know specifically Danny because she
has these three large dragon so I kind
of thought well why would she find it
hard to you know believe that there'd be
other creatures out there but when you
think about it no one believes this
threat pretty much everybody that you
know John's ever talked to about it or
anybody's ever discussed it with they've
all pretty much dismissed it as just you
know a story or a fairy tale so you know
Danny may be one of those people as well
we think you know that's kind of
ludicrous so I will definitely have to
see how that plays out and see if it's
actually true that John has to go
capture one of these to prove it to
everybody what you'd hope you wouldn't
have to do but sometimes to get
somebody's attention you can't just have
him on a shoulder you got to hit him
over the head with a hammer so he may
have to go to that extent to prove that
there is actually White Walkers so I
guess we'll just have to wait and see
says Davos tries to tell her about
John's resurrection but John dismisses
it carrion steps in to save John's a
good guy and definitely not insane now
that part I definitely believe I
definitely think tyrion would say that
John's a good guy I assumed teryn would
already have said this to Danny as
John's
traveling there to meet her so you think
by the time Danny and John met she
wouldn't ask him to Ben Denis you think
she just pulled him to the side and have
a discussion with him about her plans
and intentions and then John could tell
her about you know what he wants to do
so you think she could avoid half and
ask him to bend a knee but you know
whatever you know whatever she wants to
do is up to her she's got the large army
and big guys dragging so she could tell
pretty much anybody to do whatever she
wants but teryn and John have a pretty
good relationship and I know some people
don't believe that but
they didn't spend a whole lot of time
together but if you remember their last
conversation together it showed me at
least of how much their relationship and
bond actually grew over the time that
they spent together traveling to the
wall and being at the wall together and
when Tara and John first met John kind
of had his guard up considering Tyrion
was a Lannister he probably assumed he
was an [ __ ] like the rest of them
he probably assumed he was an [ __ ]
like Jaime if you remember when Jaime
and Jon first met Jamie was pretty much
disrespecting Jon and kind of treating
him like a child
so Jon probably assumed Tyrion would be
just like his brother like an [ __ ]
but John and tyrians last conversation
together was actually a pretty good
conversation and actually let me know
how they felt about each other at that
time and when Tyrion said he wanted to
piss off the top of the wall when he was
actually up there doing that and he
turned around to leave Jon actually said
I'm sorry to see you leave Lannister and
Tyrion said it's either me or this cold
and it doesn't appear to be going
anywhere I'm Jon I asked him if he was
going to stop at Winterfell on his way
south in Tyrion said you know I expect I
will gods know there aren't many feather
beds between here and Kings Landing and
Jon said oh if you see my little brother
bran tell him I miss him tell him I
would visit if I could in Tyrion said of
course take care of snow then they shook
hands and Jon said farewell my lord so
at this point
Jon was no longer talking down Ontarian
and Tyrion was no longer calling Jon it
bastard Jon actually said farewell my
lord and he said take care of snow and
they shook hands so they definitely grew
fond of each other by this time
Tyrion he actually saved Jon it at the
wall after John broke Grenn's nose as
they were training Jon was putting a
training swords away and that's when
grant and a couple other guys of the
Nights Watch rolled up on Jon and was
starting to rough him up and they
actually acted like they were gonna kill
him
but Tyrion stepped in and said you know
you guys had these very distinctive
faces faces that I will remember
basically faces I could tell my sister
about and pretty much have you guys
killed and that's when the guys took off
running and I think ever since then Jon
kind of respected tyrion for stepping in
and saving him like that when he didn't
have to he went out of his way to back
John up there so I could definitely see
from here on out
Tyrian back and join up again and john
he really has no reason to not like
tearing at this point either i think
they're gonna have a very good
relationship from here on out throughout
the rest of the series because Terry ins
went out of his way to be respectful to
the Starks several different times Terry
and saved John
he saved lady Catelyn even though he was
a prisoner of hers and she was taking
him to the Eyrie to stand trial they
were ambushed and Tyrion actually saved
her life when he couldn't just let her
die and he could have tried to escape
after that Tyrion built that saddle for
bran
when he didn't have to but bran respects
cripples and bastards because he's
always felt like one being an empty
police treated him and Tyrion was good
to Sansa
Sansa was forced in a marriage with him
and Tyrion could have treated her any
way he wanted he could have treated her
like a [ __ ] if he wanted to she was
there in King's Landing with no one to
protect her or for her to tell anyone
how she was being treated but Tyrion
respected her as a stark as a young lady
and he didn't do anything to disrespect
her in any way so I'm sure once Jon and
Sansa met back up and Sansa told John
about her time at King's Landing and
everything that happened when she told
John that she was forcing a marriage or
tearing that he treated her good and you
know didn't take advantage of her in any
way I think Jon would only grow fonder
of Tyrion so I could see them having a
real good relationship and I'm actually
excited to see that because in season
one some of my favorite scenes were
between Jon and Tyrion the dialogue they
had together I liked a lot so I'm
looking forward to seeing more scenes
with John and Tyrion together but let's
move forward says Danny respects Jon
immediately although Jon doesn't return
the sentiment and now I could see why
Danny would respect John immediately Jon
just kind of gives off that vibe and he
kind of looks the road like an honorable
guy
not sure why Jon wouldn't want to return
the sentiment maybe it's because she
demanded that he bend the knee I'm not
really sure you think Tyrion would you
know back Danny up to John and say hey
you know she's a good woman she wants to
roll the right way she wants to free the
slaves she wants to you know treat the
people good so I'm not sure why John
Wooden returned that sentiment so I
guess what to see how that actually
plays out and
how he feels about her he still doesn't
know he's a Targaryen and related to her
so it'll be interesting to see how they
you know present that dynamic on the
screen and says Jon meets Theon promises
to spare his life for what he did when
he helped sands escape from Ramsay
Bolton and this has already been proven
in photos as well we see Jon and Theon
on the beach together Jon has him
grabbed up around his collar and it
looks like he's screaming in his face
more than likely for what fian did at
Winterfell when he captured Winterfell
and basically held everybody there
hostage and he killed Sir Roderick by
executing him and chopping his head off
and he killed two of those farm boys who
he passed off as you know Rick Hawn and
bran so Jon's definitely gonna want to
punish Theon in some kind of way for
doing that even though he helps Sansa
what Theon did was still pretty
disrespectful he turned his back on Rob
and he basically spit on everybody at
Winterfell so I could see Jon wanting to
punish him in some sort of way beyond
just screaming in his face
I never something you disagree but
that's just how I feel and I like
feeling as a character but he's just one
of those push around type of guys so I
wouldn't be surprised to see Jon slap
him around a little bit but it says Arya
encounters her old direwolf Nymeria on a
way to Winterfell now there's no way for
me to dispute that there's really no way
for any evidence of that to come out
because Nymeria is added in
post-production with CGI so we're
probably not ever going to see a leaked
photo of them together but I actually
hope this happens we haven't seen I'm
area and Arya together since season 1
and if you know anything about Game of
Thrones if something didn't die on
screen it's more than likely still alive
so I'm pretty sure my Mary is still out
there running around somewhere and I
would definitely love to see Arya and
I'm area reunite and be together again
I like seeing a direwolf's in the show I
know they don't use them a lot but this
would be a good chance for them to bring
one back into the fold back into the
fight so hopefully that does happen and
says drawer and Sam meet Knoll town and
find a cure for greyscale now according
to Watchers on the wall this definitely
happens next season I don't know who
their sources are
but they seem to be pretty damn accurate
almost everything they come out with
seems to come true and they said in a
report that we will definitely see this
happen and by the look at the photos you
see jorah back with Daenerys and she
told him not to return until he got
cured so I'm pretty sure he would do
just that and since he's back around her
I'm assuming that he did get cured
because he probably wouldnt want to
return and you know risk spreading
greyscale so and plus he has both of his
arms so he definitely just didn't go you
know drastic and cut one of them off so
this is likely this probably does
actually happen I'm sure George gets
cured is it by Sam or not I don't know
we know Sam's at the Citadel training we
know jor is the son of Sam's old Lord
Commander at Castle black
the Lord Commander saved Sam's life so
I'm sure Sam would want to help Jorah
given the chance so that's pretty likely
I think it says brand arrives at
Winterfell when Mary returns home to the
neck now I can only assume brand arrives
at Winterfell because he's right outside
the wall he knows the white Walker
threat is pretty damn big right now and
are closing in on him he has to mark
they know where he's at so I could
definitely see him wanting to get safe
and Watchers on the wall also reported
that we're going to get the stark
reunion next year between bran Arya and
Sansa so until they prove me wrong with
any of their you know leaked information
I can only believe what they say because
they haven't proven me wrong yet there's
no photos to confirm this yet but I'm
going to assume that this does happen
and I guess me report would return onto
the neck because now that bran would be
safe there'd really be no reason for her
to stick around so I could see her going
home and hopefully when she goes home
she talks to her dad
hopefully bran says hey Mary when you
get home till your dad I need to speak
to him I saw him in one of my visions
and I'm gonna need him to help me
confirm John's parentage he was there he
probably knows some stuff and Alan Reid
may even know where the sword dawn
actually is I know it was said that Ned
returned it back to its home but you
never really know man they could have
did something else with that sword it
could be in the crypts I mean who really
knows Howland Reed could have it stashed
somewhere
so hopefully Howlin Reed does
into the play and you know he spiced his
[ __ ] up in some way he reveals some
information that we've been wondering
and you know if they bring how and read
into the story
I think things could get pretty damn
interesting so hopefully when Mary goes
home she tells her dad you know start by
wonderful so she could talk to bran
or he could talk to brain sorry so
that's it for episode three 90% of it
seems like it's probably true and the
other 10% just hasn't been confirmed by
any photos yet but so far the first
three episodes seem to be pretty damn
legit most of it has been confirmed with
photos so I have no reason to dispute it
really but give me your guys thoughts I
know some of you still think all this is
completely made-up so tell me what part
of this you think is made-up I mean I
show you proof in a lot of these photos
but some of you think and interpret
those photos in a different way than me
but I've taken my face value and what it
looks like in those photos is exactly
what it's saying in this leak so to me
it seems to be true so far so comment
below tell me what you think about this
stuff I hope you guys have a good
Thanksgiving today wasn't sure if I was
going to put a video out or not but I
already ate dinner I'm taking a break
from football I wanted to get something
out to you guys to thank you guys for
support me and leave the nice comments
and liking my stuff and subscribe and I
appreciate you guys so happy
Thanksgiving to you I hope you have a
good day and I'll see you guys next time
bye